[Musique]
élu du département et gestionnaire des
espaces naturels sensibles lancent
officiellement la 17e édition de la Fête
de la nature du 24 au 28 mai prochain
sur 35 sites naturels répartis sur
l'ensemble de l'île vous pourrez voyager
avec émotion au cœur de la biodiversité
réunionnaise si vous venez sur les ns de
Cap Blanc il suffit dans les Hauts
d'arrivée de la rivière engin vous allez
découvrir des truies un paysage
magnifique sur les montagnes de grands
coudes et la crête et également la
rivière qui s'y coule sur un kilomètre
600 sur le ns de l'Ermitage on va vous
emmener découvrir les polypes et toutes
les autres espèces qui vivent au sein du
récif corallien repas ambiance ce pays
et lendemain matin un bon réchauffé donc
avec bivouac pour ceux qui souhaitent
donc rester audit métier le samedi soir
pendant la Fête de la Nature sur le site
de durée nous n'aurons une belle visite
guidée avec un point de vue sur Salazie
et au retour tout ce qui concerne les
abeilles avec fabrication des bougies la
cire dégustation de miel etc voilà c'est
ça durer les visites guidées sont
gratuites et accessibles à tous les
publics le département ouvre ses plus
beaux espaces naturels avec comme guide
les gestionnaires des sites et les
partenaires il va y avoir sur ces sur
ces sites 120 à peu près activités
animations visite guidées sur site 45
animations pédagogiques également sur
site donc j'invite vraiment l'ensemble
des Réunionnaises des Réunionnais à
venir s'imprégner de la nature lors de
ces événements du mois de mai le
département géant la nature à la Réunion
pourra dire ça de façon un peu
synthétique comme cela et il était
important de faire découvrir redécouvrir
nos espaces naturels qui sont vraiment
très bien gérés par nos différents
gestionnaires que ce soit les
associations que ce soit la SPL Eden
pour profiter de cette nouvelle édition
de la Fête de la nature et de ses
activités vous pouvez faire votre
réservation par téléphone retrouvez tout
le programme sur le
www.département974.fr
[Musique]